creo que ya sabemos lo suficiente acerca
de las ventas cortas para ver un vídeo
un poco más difícil
este es el gráfico de una acción y por
lo tanto aquí voy a tener el eje del
tiempo y este base del eje del precio y
también voy a suponer que no hay
personas que se dedican a la venta corta
de acción y este universo parece ser un
universo favorable porque fíjense en
este momento aquí empiezan a comprar la
acción y después quién sabe por qué pero
deciden vender la acción y por lo tanto
el peso de la acción baja y después
llega un punto en el que es factible
otra vez comprar la acción porque la
oferta es un poquito más grande que la
demanda y eso hace que la gráfica
empiece a subir otra vez y así se sigue
sucesivamente durante toda la gráfica y
así y dado que hemos hablado de las
ventas cortas qué va a pasar en el
escenario en que esta acción tenga unas
ventas cortas y pues bueno hay dos casos
primero vamos a ver el caso en el que tú
logras hacer dinero porque realizas una
buena venta corta por lo tanto qué es lo
que va a pasar cuando tenemos una
gráfica cerca del precio de la acción y
bueno si tú eres un buen vendedor de
ventas
y de hecho es más si tú eres un perfecto
vendedor de ventas cortas lo que vas a
hacer es vender en los picos déjame
sacar otro color para que se vea mucho
más claro todo lo que vas a hacer es
vender aquí que por cierto en
matemáticas a esto se le conoce como un
máximo local y vas a comprar aquí en los
mínimos locales y con ello vas a obtener
lo que está aquí en esta línea de
ganancia y bueno como él es un perfecto
vendedor entonces vas a vender aquí vas
a comprar acá vas a vender aquí y vas a
comprar acá y por lo tanto vas a vender
en los máximos locales y vas a comprar
en los mismos locales y vas a obtener
todo esto de ganancia y bueno así
sucesivamente en cada máximo y en cada
mínimo de toda esta gráfica aquí hay
otro ejemplo vas a vender aquí vamos a
comprar acá y va a sostener todo esto en
ganancia y así durante todo el tiempo
pero bueno recuerda que estamos hablando
acerca de una persona que es perfecto en
las ventas cortas y bueno esta persona
parece ser que tiene una gran capacidad
de análisis y además como que tiene una
capacidad de ser un profeta de las
finanzas y una gran predicción de qué es
lo qué va
y además de eso una capacidad paranormal
para entender todas estas finanzas ahora
hasta aquí tenemos la gráfica en verde
que no tenía nada que ver con las
personas que se dedicaban a las ventas
cortas por lo tanto esta gráfica va a
cambiar cuando llega el vendedor de
ventas cortas y por lo tanto lo que va a
pasar es lo siguiente este pico que
tenemos aquí va a disminuir su tamaño y
esto debido a que cuando tú tienes una
venta corta vendes la acción por lo
tanto aumenta su oferta y bueno es que
recuerda que cuando tú aumentas la
oferta va a disminuir el precio pero eso
no es todo ahora que llegamos al mínimo
lo que va a pasar es que también va a
cambiar la gráfica porque como tú vas a
comprar la acción entonces van a cambiar
los compradores y por lo tanto el precio
va a aumentar y esto va a pasar en cada
máximo y en cada mismo de esta gráfica
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un máximo muy
grande y por lo tanto tú vas a vender la
acción lo que hace que aumente la oferta
y eso hace que el precio disminuya y
llegamos a que otro mínimo y pasó lo
mismo tú vas a comprar esta acción por
lo tanto van a aumentar los compradores
y por lo tanto el precio va a aumentar y
así sucesivamente durante todo
la gráfica y es que recuerda que es
justo eso lo que tiene que hacer una
buena persona para las ventas cortas
vender en los máximos y comprar en los
mínimos y justo esto hasta que cambie la
volatilidad de esta acción y recuerda
cambiar la volatilidad siempre es bueno
para todos es bueno para el mercado es
bueno para el propietario de estas
acciones y también para aquellos que
expidan estas acciones la compañía que
va a expedir estas acciones y también
claro está para el que va a realizar la
venta corta y bueno ahorita que lo
pienso no hay gran diferencia entre una
persona que se dedica a las ventas
cortas y un comprador regular y es justo
lo que logramos porque cuando nosotros
compramos y vendemos compramos y
vendemos una acción lo que hacemos es
que reduce el precio de la acción y por
lo tanto la volatilidad de la acción
disminuye y todos salimos ganando es muy
bueno ser el propietario de una acción
que tenga una gráfica como ésta hacer el
titular de una acción que tenga una
gráfica como ésta roja que estoy
dibujando aquí porque la diferencia es
justo lo que acabamos de ver la
volatilidad de esta acción pero bueno
en la vida real suele pasar esto hay
muchas personas que se dedican a las
ventas cortas y lo que hacen es
disminuir la volatilidad pero el
problema es que no son perfectos como el
que acabamos de imaginar realmente
cometen muchos errores y por lo tanto
ocurre lo siguiente supongamos que
nosotros tenemos un operador o alguna
persona que se dedique a las ventas
cortas y entonces decide comprar hasta
camps y después quiere vender la acción
perderán miedo venderla en el punto
adecuado entonces se va hasta acá y
entonces la acción es difícil de vender
y lo que pasa es que la acción subió
bastante de precio y esto hace que la
volatilidad de esta acción aumente y por
lo tanto esto perjudica a todos pero
realmente las personas que se dedican a
las ventas cortas hacen que esto se
descontrolen y bueno realmente ellos
también tienen una cierta penalización
la penalización es que pierdan dinero o
que no vendan en los puntos adecuados y
por lo tanto no van a obtener la
ganancia que quieren o inclusive pueden
perder dinero y esto los hace unas
personas muy malas para las ventas
cortas y por lo tanto son personas que
son muy malas invirtiendo y pueden
llegar a perder su dinero y ya está la
camiseta y bueno para que quede todo
esto mucho más claro voy a agarrar otra
pantalla y lo que voy a querer hacer en
esta pantalla es hacer una lista de los
incentivos positivos y los incentivos
negativos para realizar una venta corta
de una acción aquí voy a tener que
factores positivos afectan al mercado en
el que está la acción y en la parte
derecha voy a tener los factores
negativos no me gusta más la palabra
indagar cuáles son los factores que
indagan indagar y es que realmente yo le
quiero dar un contexto negativo a esto
indagar es una palabra que puede tener
un contexto positivo o negativo depende
de la situación
que estoy haciendo mi pantalla aquí
tengo un pequeño de error con el puntero
pero bueno ya lo resolví cuál es el
primer factor positivo ya saben esta
pluma en la menopausia perdón el primer
factor positivo que tiene una acción es
la sociedad gerente y es que la sociedad
gerente es justo lo que hace funcionar a
la compañía porque ellos tienen la
cualidad de tener la mayor transparencia
acerca de las finanzas de la economía y
ellos tienden en general a hacerlos
mayores accionistas de la empresa o de
su dado caso en obtener una compensación
basada en la dinámica de la acción y es
por eso que ellos son muy importantes
son muy positivos por así decirlo cuando
hablamos acerca de la dinámica de una
acción ellos tienen la verdad cuando las
cosas están mal ahora bien otra de las
grandes influencias que tiene una acción
es la prensa financiera y antes de
hablar de manera positiva o negativa
acerca de la prensa financiera es decir
si hace que bombé el presión acción o en
su dado caso que indague de manera
positiva o tal vez negativa el precio de
una acción vamos a hablar acerca de
dónde sacas dinero una prensa financiera
y es justo lo que quiero preguntarles la
próxima vez que vea en el canal de cnpc
lo que quiero es que se pregunten no
cuánto afecta a la acción sino de dónde
saca dinero este tipo de canales y bueno
la respuesta es vendiendo anuncios lo
que hacen es vender anuncios pero de que
ya no se van a vender será acaso
anuncios de trapeadores o de
hamburguesas
y ellos venden anuncios de las acciones
ellos venden anuncios financieros es así
dan anuncios a las empresas que dan
servicios financieros es decir personas
que manejan tu riqueza accionistas casas
de bolsa corredores de bolsa compañías
de fondos mutuos y toda aquella persona
que está interesada en invertir en
publicidad pero ojo no todos son
candidatos a clientes de la prensa
financiera
por ejemplo los fondos de alto riesgo no
son candidatos de esta prensa financiera
pero bueno entonces quién es y ha
puestos clientes son los administradores
del dinero los planificadores
financieros los corredores de bolsa
las empresas de fondo mutuo y todos
ellos se benefician cuando sus acciones
suben de precio en el mercado y bueno
obviamente las empresas de fondo mutuo
encuentran administradores tales que
bueno ellos lo que quieren es pensar a
futuro y por lo tanto lo que ellos
quieren es que las acciones suban por
ejemplo seguramente también debemos de
pensar que un corredor de bolsa lo que
hace es asesorarte acerca de decir una
acción sube o baja de precio para que tú
puedas realizar una venta corta o en su
caso
tú puedas vender una acción y que
seguramente ellos solamente se hacen
ricos con las transacciones que tú
realices pero en general la gente está
invirtiendo más y más dinero en el
mercado pensando en que el mercado
crezca y seguramente por eso estás
pensando que la gente está invirtiendo
más días en nuevas transacciones en la
bolsa y entonces el mercado le está
yendo bastante bien sin embargo lo que
está ocurriendo actualmente es que la
gente está quitando dinero del mercado y
si la gente está quitando dinero del
mercado entonces a los primeros que
afectasen a los corredores de bolsa a
los administradores de bolsa y por lo
tanto por ellos ahorita no tienen dinero
para anunciarse en la prensa financiera
y si no tienen dinero para anunciarse en
la empresa financiera y entonces la
prensa financiera va a terminar poniendo
anuncios de trapeadores o de
hamburguesas y es justo por eso que a mí
me gusta pensar que la prensa financiera
es positiva para una acción otro factor
positivo son aquellos que hacen el
análisis acerca de la parte compradora o
la parte vendedora con el cual ese
análisis le sirve bastante a los bancos
de inversión ya los corredores de bolsa
porque ellos publican los reportes de la
clasificación de las ventas y de la
compra de acciones por ejemplo de ibm
o de lo que sea y se llaman análisis de
la parte compradora porque lo que hacen
es vender o comprar según sea el caso
seguridad financiera y servicios
financieros a personas que quieran ser
una adquisición en una empresa o
corredores de bolsa o en su dado caso a
aquellos que van a tener un riesgo
invertir su dinero en la bolsa de
valores pero bueno si lo que quisiéramos
pensar es en algún factor negativo para
la acción podremos pensar en el gobierno
pero que creen si pensamos por un
momento del gobierno el gobierno intenta
hacer crecer el mercado de acciones o al
menos eso es lo que intenta porque el
aumentar el mercado de acciones la
economía va a mejorar y por lo tanto el
gobierno no tiene que preocuparse por
ello las clases sociales se vuelven más
homogéneas y por lo tanto si le quitamos
la parte negativa y lo pensamos de un
punto mucho más crítico podremos llegar
a la conclusión de que el gobierno si es
positivo para la acción y tan positivo
casi como la sociedad gerente o
inclusive las compañías financieras y
por lo tanto voy a poner aquí el
gobierno y claro aquí hace falta algo no
hay que olvidarnos de los bancos los
bancos y el gobierno regulan el manejo
de la economía
y el gobierno en su caso también las
leyes por lo tanto lo voy a poner aquí
bancos y gobiernos y estos dos son
factores positivos y bueno también nos
hacen falta las agencias de
clasificación o las agencias de 'rating'
estas agencias operan en el mundo de las
deudas y aunque esto lo voy a tratar con
mucha más calma en los próximos vídeos
lo que sí quiero decirles es que si tú
indagas en una compañía en sus niveles
de deudas ellos lo hacen y pueden
concluir por ejemplo o bueno esta
compañía no le va nada bien y por lo
tanto no creo que pueda pagar sus deudas
y entonces eso mata sus acciones eso es
una parte negativa sin embargo este tipo
de agencias de clasificación están
pagadas por el banco y por lo tanto
tienen que ser un factor positivo o un
incentivo positivo para la acción y
bueno toda esta gente es un factor
positivo para las acciones y si pensamos
en un factor que no sea siempre positivo
y bueno es que toda esta gente no tiene
de otras siempre va a buscar que mejoren
el precio de las acciones y sin embargo
los únicos que pueden indagar en el
precio de una acción afectando la
positiva o negativamente son las
personas que se dedican a las ventas
pues ellos son los únicos que tienen el
incentivo económico a su favor y por lo
tanto le dedican tiempo a ello son ellos
los que analizan lo que la sociedad
gerente hace son ellos los que analizan
los libros y son ellos los que tratan de
descifrar el rompecabezas acerca de las
finanzas y son ellos los que concluyen
que los números no están siempre del
todo bien y una empresa por ejemplo
puede estar sobrevalorada y por lo tanto
ellos son parte de estas clases sociales
y pueden prevenir el optimismo constante
de una gerencia y resolver el acertijo y
no es que yo esté a favor o
completamente a favor de las personas
que se dedican a las ventas cortas hay
personas que se dedican a las ventas
cortas y realmente son muy malas pues a
ellos les conviene esparcir rumores
falsos acerca de las acciones 10 más por
eso lo voy a escribir aquí lo que logran
es tener una manipulación del mercado
más esparcir rumores por lo tanto lo voy
a poner aquí rumores sin embargo con
toda mi experiencia lo que les puedo
decir es que no todas las personas que
se dedican a las ventas cortas son así
además que uno corre un riesgo si se
porta de manera inadecuada pues si te
logran atrapar puedes obtener una
penalización por ello ahora bien si yo
tuviera que elegir entre estas personas
que tengo aquí y las personas que se
dedican a las ventas cortas sobre cuál
de los dos dicen menos me dicen menos
mentiras o esparcen menos rumores y
bueno lo digo con experiencia yo creo
que son más culpables todas estas
personas que las personas que se dedican
a las ventas cortas puede ser muy raro
encontrar a una persona que se dedique a
las ventas cortas que tenga la mala
intención de querer arruinar las
acciones y bueno si hay casos pero
aunque no quiero profundizar mucho en
ello yo creo que son pocos las personas
que se dedican las ventas cortas que
crean este tipo de malestares y bueno
este vídeo está sino larguísimo y espero
que te haya servido para crear un
análisis sobre si es buena o si es mala
una venta corta y además de todo esto
espero que te haya servido para crear
una opinión acerca de las personas que
se dedican a las ventas cortas nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo